[Applause]
all right but first up
look i know you're not a fan of this guy
but be nice
he is one of the most influential person
around today he is the former white
house chief strategist for president
trump steve bannon is over here steve
bannon
hey that's not so bad
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you steve all right steve well it
took a lot of prepping to get the
audience to be that nice to you
yeah yeah but i'm gonna say to you what
i always say to conservatives when they
come here first of all thank you
i appreciate it and it says volumes why
the republicans are in power and we have
none hillary clinton never came here
maybe she'd be president if she were
more confident big time
yeah so and and i know that
uh you know you had a little event there
at the new yorker they had a festival
in fact i want to read malcolm
gladwell's quote because they were going
to interview you
yep and then you were disinvited i've
been disinvited many times by the way
it's a good club
and malcolm gladwell said call me
old-fashioned but i would have thought
that the point of a festival of ideas
was to expose the audience to ideas
if you only invite your friends over
it's called a dinner party yeah
what are your thoughts on that well they
chased me for uh
you know david remnick chased me for a
year to be on his podcast and he came to
me and said hey we'd be honored if you
were in this festival ideas
i said fine i don't want compensation
but i like going into hostile audiences
with tough interviewers i mean you know
i do very little conservative media now
i do
cnn bbc you know the economist
i go to the toughest places toughest
toughest interviewers and say hey no
holds barred
hostile audiences let's get it on and
again that's why the republicans are in
power so let me ask you about i think it
does sharpen
it sharpens the blade it does um let me
pick your brain about the democrats
because you're a strategist and you got
your boy elected but no one said that
could happen
donald trump got himself elected um
i was just i just i just showed up and
steve realigned
i i don't want to get on this but first
you were crazy about sarah palin
and then you were crazy about donald
trump i think you look for morons
who are empty vessels that you could put
more ideas
you you steve
every single person in administration
has called him an idiot
that's what you look for i get it no no
you're not by the way by the way we'll
get into it as you get into his uh
economic war china do you see what he's
doing to realign
the world's economy look did he go to uh
harvard kennedy school does he speak in
the vernacular of the elites of this
world no he speaks in a very plain
spoken vernacular but he's incredibly
smart
he is i'm not it's not his syntax that
i'm worried about
it's did you did you see his press
conference this week
he says crazy [ __ ] that no one thinks is
true you don't think it's but
no but here's the power of the press
conference no other gutless republican
would go into that lions den for an hour
and 20 minutes and take all the incoming
he he stood up for kavanaugh more than
any of these guys did and i think it's
one of the things that empowered
kavanaugh
to go into on on thursday and and to
take on the democrats if trump had not
done that
you know and by the way he did have some
ques he did have some answers
that were not the standard answers but
look he's got his he's got his own
absolutely not true he's actually more
grounded and that speech to the u.n
no the speed he said china loves me
because i have a big big brain
steve a very big brain whatever it is
now let me ask you this if any other
president
just one day got up and talked like that
the markets would crash and you'd have a
heart attack
it's just that we're a frog in the pot
and we see it every day
so we built bill he's created 10
trillion remember when he's got elected
what nobody thought he was the market is
going to crash
okay he's created 10 trillion dollars
the market was going to crash remember
when he won everybody said the market's
going to crash
it's armageddon that's the one i got
wrong no but it will though
my point is he's got it will my point is
he's got a very fundamental plan of how
he's turning around this economy
he's actually i think i think you guys
missed the point when you you
you separate the signal from the noise
watch the signal there's
a flashbang grenade every day as far as
the noise goes right
but just watch the signal he's very
consistent that speech at the u.n well
you know what the signal that was sent
with the tax cut didn't reach your base
they either
reality one bill reality won once
because
wait a second they know that that tax
cut 83
of it went to the top one percent they
know that
and they don't like it okay and what
happens
i was the guy in the oval office that
was pushing uh
you know a 44 tax rate for those over
five million bucks
and to take the three trillion dollars
that were repatriated and make sure hold
it make sure there were different tax
structures
so it would be invested in uh plant
equipment in inner cities
now the overall tax plan i think works
for workers and here's why you've got to
look at it in context
of our economic war china you can't
separate the tariffs
and what he's doing on the 301s what
he's doing on trying to stop
intellectual property
theft and appropriation from the taxes
the taxes principally
were to make our companies competitive
with german germany and china
the the the personal tax rates which i
didn't totally agree with right because
it's more of the trickle down
uh is something that had to be used to
get this thing passed but the central
part of it
was the corporate taxes isn't that what
a con man does he said i'm going to look
out for you the common man the forgotten
americans
and then he gets in there and tries to
steal their health care to pay for the
tax cut
for them how is that
[Applause]
the central part of this bill was
bringing manufacturing jobs back from
east asia
and that's what he's doing the tax cuts
for corporations make him competitive
with china and germany
the tariffs are part of an economic war
that china has forced it upon us for the
last 25 years
and this is all of whole cloth and
that's why it's working he's reorienting
bill
the world supply chain right now with
china on as far as i can
to get you on this next question okay
i want to eventually i want to pick your
brain on the democrats okay because i
you of all people i want the answer to
this who scares you who do you think
could do good
how do you handicap the people what do
you think about uh
elizabeth warren what do you think about
bernie sanders what do you think about
kamala harris do you think about gavin
newsom what do you
okay i know you like them all what eric
holder what do you think about all these
people and then i say michael avenatti i
saw that tweeties
wrote the other day and i said he could
be the trump
of 2020 the guy who's the outsider who
like blows through the regular
politician because he looks different in
his game
if bernie sanders had an ounce of
avenetti's fearlessness
he would have been the democratic
nominee and we would have a much tougher
time
bernie doesn't have fearlessness not not
like avenatti avenatti and i i've not
done any due diligence on this game
right
he's got a fearlessness right and he's a
fighter he's a fighter he's right
i think he'll go through a lot of this
field if he decides to stick with it
like assisted grass
now i don't happen to think a
professional politician
because i think we're in a new age i
don't think a professional politician is
going to be there at the end of the day
i've always said it's going to be
something like oprah
or an avenetti or somebody that's more
media savvy is going to be there but i
think one thing people you think that's
good
i think it's i think it's just a reality
of today i think you need to know how to
handle mascara first
if i can say one thing i do think this
campaign after november 6 which is
really trump's first reelect
if we lose the house he's going to get
impeached this is a referendum on him
if we get past that if we get
well if if if if we get past that i
think in
in 2020 you're going to have trump on
the right
uh a politician maybe a camilla harrison
somebody on the left and i think you'll
have a bloomberg or
romney or somebody in the center i think
it'll be a three-way round i hope so
because if it's a three-way they will
take away enough votes to make sure
donald trump never wins again but
let now now that we're talking about by
the way his first term is going to be so
successful look it's four percent growth
we're so tired of winning steve
economy's on
i'll come back here i'll come back here
during 2020 we'll talk about okay
um but speaking of elections i would
love to know what advice
you would give to donald trump if he
didn't leave
even after he lost because i saw hillary
clinton you're obsessed with this
i am obsessed you're obsessed with this
wait do you think he's not going to
leave wait a second just because i know
he's having the time
because he's an insane narcissist
who talks all the time about how we
should have a president for life
let me read what hillary said because
you're right people have been saying i'm
an alarmist and i'm crazy because i keep
saying he's not going to leave even if
he loses
now crooked hillary is saying
she said this she said you remember the
moment in the third debate when trump
refused
to pledge that he would accept the
result of the vote
that's where it started he said it took
my breath away even the moderator from
fox news couldn't believe it i felt the
foundations of our democracy tremble
imagine if trump does the same thing in
2020
what happens now this is this is the
reason she's not president i mean this
is the kind of this is
this is the kind of gobbledygook so
you're saying he will go if he loses
oh i don't think it's a question
absolutely i mean it's not even i mean
that's that's absurd
but you didn't think you'd get fired
well i remember remember remember
you've got i'm just i'm just saying i
only gave it one year
i only gave it i only gave it one year i
only gave him one
read read the book i quote i will read
the book but why why i mean he was mean
to you he fired you he said mean things
he does by everybody i've been working
on this project i've worked on the
populist movement for nine years i was
on your show
five years ago making a film about sarah
palin yeah we were trying to drive this
populist movement yeah you know donald
trump came along at a time that this
populist movement was starting to get
going and he really took it ten years
into the future
i mean he was he was a guy that got it
right away that had this populist
tendencies
understood economic nationalism and cut
through an entire cut through the bush
apparatus cut through the entire
republican field
and then took on the clintons and if
bernie had had the type of fight and
fearlessness that trump had
he would won the democratic primary and
then we would have had left-wing
populism and right-wing populism
fight it out in 2016. but you're a guy
who is again
the thing i've been saying that people
were criticizing me for using the word
treason
and now i hear it more but you said the
same thing you said the trump tower
meeting was treason
i said i said for paul manafort i
corrected myself or whatever the the
book had okay
no no no look i and people people
other people in the republican party
disagree with me i don't think i don't
think that meaning was appropriate i
don't think you reach out to appropriate
foreign sources i don't think you reach
out to foreign appropriate is quite a
bit less than true all you need it by
the way
all you needed was clinton cash we had
done all the research we've created the
book and
done done the uh done the film to to
show that clinton's corruption
all you need to do is go into clinton
cast the foundation when you see these
people with those t-shirts that say i'd
rather be with russia
than a democrat what do you think about
it
here's what i think you see that can't
be a positive no no no
people would rather side with another
country than america
and and it can't be a positive
development when when our own president
attacks our own fbi can it
look on the on the first thing is that
the country's divided i mean the
country's been divided before you're not
going to hug this one divided i never
remember
lincoln going after the fbi i know there
was no fbi
lincoln went after some guys to to win
no i think the president what the
president
you know is said and what these people
are saying is that you know we're very
divided now and it's not appropriate to
say i'd rather be with russia than
democrats but i think it shows you the
vitra this film i just made
trump at war i start with five minutes
with don lemon kind of lecturing
trump supporters why trump's not the
racist why they're the racist okay and
we intercut
we intercut by the way because it's
upping people's girls we intercut it
with antifa
kicking the [ __ ] out of guys in red ball
cap oh steve
i you know i know you i know you can put
that idea in people's heads but just
between me and you you don't believe it
i know you don't i don't you i don't
think you really think they're the
racists and not your people
you i don't think i do you don't think
poppy some of populism
isn't some of that really isn't that
racist look at look in italy right now
you got the five-star movement
yeah you got the league the five-star
movement is is is
is so green they don't want a bullet
train okay they're the populist movement
and they're even saying hey we gotta
stop the migrant issue because they're
the ones who want to give a guaranteed
income
i don't populism populism is not based
on racism right
it's based on the little guy the little
guy having a voice who you are always
saying should have a voice yes
you're actually a populist okay come
back and let's talk just about that
issue because i want to get into that
with you and i know for both sort of
students of history
and you know you're good to come here
but
history not going to be kind steve
thank you we'll see though huh all right
i'll see you later
steve madden